Salut ! Le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
et le mercredi je vous donne toujours une astuce !
Et cette semaine je vous donne mon astuce pour contacter n'importe qui dans le monde, n'importe quelle personne.
Que cette personne soit célèbre, soit complètement anonyme, habite en Afrique, aux Etats-Unis, sur une petite île perdue au fin fond du Pacifique !
Je vais vous donner une solution pour pouvoir la contacter
tout du moins pour pouvoir atteindre cette personne
grâce à la théorie des cinq poignées de main.
En cinq poignées de main on peut contacter quelqu'un.
On appelle ça aussi les cinq degrés de séparation.
Cinq degrés de séparation qui réunissent six personnes
C'est une théorie un petit peu ouf
qui dit que deux personnes dans le monde peuvent être reliées via cinq poignées de main au grand maximum.
Elle ne sort pas de n'importe où cette théorie.
En 1929, le journaliste et écrivain Karinthy a écrit une nouvelle qui s'appelle "Chaînes"
et c'est à l'intérieur même de cette nouvelle qu'il élabore toutes ses théories et qu'il nous en fait part.
Et en 1967 Stanley Milgram s'y intéresse aussi.
Milgram vous le connaissez peut-être via une autre expérience qui a fait en fait un peu sa renommée
qui s'appelle simplement "l'expérience de Milgram".
C'est une expérience de soumission à l'autorité.
Un jour je vous en parlerai parce qu'elle est vraiment intéressante
Elle a été reprise avec des moyens un peu plus modernes.
Peut-être même la semaine prochaine je vous parle de Milgram.
Donc en 1967, Milgram décrit ce qu'il appelle "le phénomène du petit monde"
Il a écrit un ouvrage là-dessus.
Dans le temps, on appellera ça plus simplement "le paradoxe de Milgram".
Le phénomène du petit monde décrit que plus le temps passe plus les moyens de communication simplifient la vie
plus on connaît de personnes, plus le monde se rétrécit en terme de contact.
Peut-être que dans les années 1500 il était très compliqué de contacter quelqu'un qui habitait sur un autre continent.
En 2008 il y a deux personnes de chez Microsoft qui se sont dit : "Mais attend on va essayer d'avoir un vrai chiffre par rapport à ça."
Ils ont étudié, ils étaient deux : Eric Horvitz et Jules Leskovec
Ils ont clairement analysé le web
tout ce qui était Facebook qui émergeait réellement aussi en Europe en 2008.
ils ont bien entendu travaillé sur Messenger parce qu'ils avaient accès à toutes les données.
N'oublions pas quand même que le but des réseaux sociaux c'est de récupérer de la data en fait, ce que l'on appelle du big data
C'est-à-dire toutes nos informations pour les revendre, s'en servir et les revendre.
Et nos deux geeks ont déterminé en 2008 que le lien était descendu à 4,74 contacts pour aboutir à n'importe qui dans le monde.
C'est-à-dire qu'en faisant marcher son réseau on doit pouvoir, en passant d'une poignée de main à l'autre, contacter n'importe qui en cinq étapes maximum.
Alors évidemment il faudrait prendre en compte : Est-ce que cette personne-là veut bien nous présenter à l'autre personne ? Est-ce que tout ça est possible ?
Mais ce n'est que de la théorie en fait et théoriquement on peut.
J'ai pris au hasard deux personnes pour faire un exemple et voir si c'était possible de les contacter ou pas.
Pour le premier exemple j'ai tapé "personnalité connue du monde politique mondial".
Sans grande surprise j'ai "Obama" qui est sorti
Et ma question est : Est-ce que votre mère peut contacter Obama en suivant ce théorème ? Bonne question !
Votre mère elle vous connaît vous, là c'est dans du cercle très proche, si on élargit vous vous me connaissez.
Bah oui on se connaît vu qu'on se parle, puisque quand vous mettez un commentaire je vous réponds
quand vous me parlez aussi sur les réseaux sociaux je vous réponds aussi, par mail aussi donc on se connaît.
Vous avez un vrai moyen de me contacter.
Moi je connais quelqu'un qui s'appelle Eric Bouvron, c'est un artiste, c'est aussi un metteur en scène
et il monte des plateaux comme ça d'artistes dans le 78 mais surtout il s'occupe d'une association qui s'appelle "Rire pour guérir".
Et Eric Bouvron je sais qu'il connaît le médecin de Nicolas Sarkozy.
Bah oui, lui aussi se soigne, tout le monde se soigne, tout le monde a besoin d'un toubib
et je sais qu'il connaît l'un de ses toubibs parce que je l'ai rencontré une fois, en fait on s'est croisé.
Donc je connais Eric Bouvron, c'est un autre maillon et Eric Bouvron connaît le médecin de Nicolas Sarkozy donc c'est un autre maillon aussi.
Ça a l'air de fonctionner !
Donc le médecin de Nicolas Sarkozy connaît qui ? Bah Nicolas Sarkozy ! J'ai un peu vendu la mèche en disant ça, j'aurais pu mettre un poil de suspens.
Donc on a encore un maillon qui fonctionne et Nicolas Sarkozy, par ses anciennes fonctions, a forcément le contact d'Obama.
Donc si on admettait que tous les maillons veulent bien se présenter les uns aux autres
On peut dire que votre mère, en six poignées de main, a moyen de contacter Mr Obama.
On l'invite à dîner ?
Pour le deuxième exemple, j'ai tapé "personne très populaire dans la musique" sur google.
J'ai "Stromaé" qui est sorti donc la question : Est-ce que vous pouvez contacter Stromaé ?
Je me suis de nouveau intégré dans la boucle des poignées de main parce que je ne connais pas forcément votre réseau
donc au moins je suis sûr que nous deux on se connaît.
Donc vous me contactez, premier contact, moi je contacte Diablo.
Vous vous souvenez ? C'est mon régisseur, on avait fait une vidéo avec lui et Garry qui sont mes deux régisseurs dans une des premières vidéos du Mental Vlog.
Diablo en plus de travailler avec moi, il travaille à La Sirène qui est une salle de spectacle de musique actuelle en fait à La Rochelle
donc il connaît personnellement le directeur de La Sirène. Nouveau contact !
Le directeur de la Sirène a reçu en tournée Stromaé mais forcément il ne l'a pas rencontré
enfin en tout cas je ne pense pas qu'ils se soient rencontrés vraiment individuellement.
Par contre il était en relation avec le directeur de la tournée de Stromaé donc là on a encore un maillon qui marche
et le directeur de la tournée de Sromaé est forcément en contact permanent avec Stromaé.
Donc on a : moi, Diablo, le directeur de La Sirène, le directeur de tournée de Stromaé et Stromaé.
En cinq contacts vous avez accès à Stromaé !
Je ne vous promets pas que ça va marcher simplement par contre mais sur le papier le paradoxe de Milgram fonctionne.
C'est très intéressant parce qui si on prend le temps de faire ça
on se rend compte par contre que techniquement on peut vraiment joindre des gens qu'on pensait pas joignables en fait directement.
Alors que si on prend le temps d'établir comme ça un schéma cohérent
En quelques étapes, peut-être moins en fait suivant vos besoins, vous pouvait contacter la personne
dont vous avez besoin professionnellement, amicalement...
Donc mon astuce elle se résume à ça en fait.
Si on prend ce théorème-là ça veut dire qu'il ne faut pas se figer et se braquer
à essayer de contacter directement quelqu'un sans y arriver.
Il vaut mieux prendre le temps d'établir comme ça un schéma de poignée de main en poignée de main
pour aboutir à une personne
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu !
Si c'est le cas vous mettez un petit pouce en l'air et vous pouvez mettre un petit commentaire aussi,  ça me fait plaisir
Faites moi rêver ! Vous pouvez me mettre vos propres schémas un peu loufoques.
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne, c'est extrêmement important.
Pourquoi c'est important de s'abonner à la chaîne ?
Parce qu'après vous êtes mis au courant de mes nouvelles vidéos quand vous allez sur youtube
et puis elles sont mieux diffusées.
Donc abonnez-vous, c'est hyper important et en plus c'est super encourageant.
Vous pouvez aussi venir me voir en spectacle soit avec les Hallucinations Collectives le 28 mars au Grand Point Virgule
Soit avec mon spectacle Fabien Olicard vous mentalise, en tournée.
Je vais jouer à Vert-Saint-Denis le 12 mars
je vais être également à l'entrepôt théâtre à Mulhouse.
Il y a toutes les dates de tournée de toute manière qui vont être mises sur le site.
En attendant je vous donne rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog, Tchao !